hello we're going to talk about
polygenic risk scores and specifically
the challenges that they face
in terms of implementation both at the
technological level the technical level
as well as as alluding to the issues
that face
the implementation of polygenic risk
scores in terms of the
you know the regulatory and the business
model considerations but really focusing
on the technical issues
so the challenges for the application of
polygenic risk scores
is that at present the because they are
based on
uh existing data sets of
disease they are really only applicable
to individuals of european origin
and that's because most of genetic
studies that have been carried out today
uh genome-wide association studies the
the foundation for
for polygenic risk scores almost in
almost
all of the large-scale gwa studies have
been carried out in populations of
european origin
so the solution for that of course is
ultimately to carry out large geos
studies in other population groups and
then
in terms of the utility for the patient
and for the healthcare delivery system
really that's an unexplored
area at this point three value cases
have been highlighted
but over 1500 trait uh polygenic risk
scores have been generated
um and so really what the the present
situation
is that we are faced with challenges
that we can see
glimmers of how they can be solved or we
can see clear roads to being solved but
we're still in that
in that window of time where the the um
the uh
we can see the the potential uh
applications of polygenic risk scores we
know the problems we need to address and
solve and so there's a window of
opportunity to get everything right
um and then just in terms of the
regulatory and the business model there
is not a
valid uh validation that's been done
for the for the payer and the regulatory
approval
and that's going to require investment
by someone
with a with a business model so there's
need for innovation
there as well in terms of exactly how
um polygenic risk scores will be
implemented into
into the us healthcare system
but focusing on the the technical issues
and taking a step back the goals of
human genetics
are from my formulation to predict
disease risk
and that's of benefit for population
risk prediction
for health resource planning and
allocation for individual risk predict
prediction so enabling treatment patient
management treatment and lifestyle
decisions
and then finally therapeutic
intervention so identifying reversible
processes that are driving disease
progression so we're going to focus
on you know that top part and then most
uh
for the most part on individual risk
prediction because i think that's
where uh uh that's the the the um the
appropriate place to think about
polygenic risk scores and how they uh
what the challenges are and what are the
benefits
so uh the genetic really the the
the um thinking the development of
polygenic risk scores is based on some
some kind of basic characteristics of
the genetic architecture of disease
so early on in genetics
in human genetics i should say uh there
was a focus on
a few loci of large effects that was
what we
knew how to identify how to study so
mendelian diseases recessive disease
dominant disease of large effect where
real eggs could be mapped to single loci
on the flip side starting
uh more than 10 years ago uh it's really
starting with the the welcome trust case
control consortium
uh it was identified that it was
possible to effectively measure and
identify
many loci of small effects so polygenic
so this is what i'm referring to is the
genetic architecture of disease
these two extremes in terms of genetic
effects
and polygenic risk scores are really
built on that those many loci
of small effects so how do we how do we
measure those
and use those many loci of small effect
to provide
a risk prediction for an individual
so uh in the earliest
days of uh the genome-wide association
studies people begin
to see if they could add together
the the um significant loci that were
identified for
any particular disease so this is not in
the very early days this example that
i'm giving here but it illustrates the
same
the same basic uh the same basic point
so this is a
from a paper in circulation where
a polygenic risk score based on 57 snips
of 57 loci
was was created so again looking at
the the allele allelic status of each
one of these loci
for an individual allows one to add
together the effects
and the effects do appear to be additive
add together the effects and produce an
aggregate risk prediction the aggregate
contribution of each of these 57 loci
so there's a couple of points one is
early efforts
focused on on loci that were
had met on their own genome-wide
significance so
an arbitrary p-value threshold
and that uh put a limitation
on the number of loci just because the
sample size
of the case control studies was uh was
early on relatively small
so the earliest uh efforts polygenic
risk scores were based on
5 10 etc loci
that had met genome-wide significance
and they did provide
risk prediction but not at a level that
was
useful for predicting risk for an
individual for making an
individual decision um as to as to
treatment or intervention so that brings
us to the second point which is shown in
the
illustrated i should say in the bottom
right and that is that
individuals if we really focus on the
red bar graphs
individuals at high genetic risk because
of
they carried the risk loci for
for many of these 57 snips they
respond well to statins in terms
of the reduction in cardiovascular risk
so that's illustrated by the fact that
the the hazard ratio there
about .56 of the individuals on statin
versus those on placebo
so that's again an important point these
57
snips when used together to to create a
polygenic risk or
led to information that was meaningful
for
treatment intervention so
the another advance which has happened
most recently
and i uh is that it was recognized
that the
limitation of only using variants
loci that had met genome-wide
significance was
somewhat arbitrary because doing a
larger study would bring
more loci into that
that significant range and so approaches
were developed for using
uh many many variants so in this case is
what's called a genome-wide polygenic
risk score which uses over six million
variants
um to construct a apologetic risk score
so as you add in more variance
of smaller effect of course each
individual one has less and less
impact on the overall score but again
you're sampling from a much larger set
and again you can see that um that there
is a a clear segregation in risk as
shown there in terms of the polygenic
risk for percentile
percentile the case control but the
other thing is because
one has so many variants um one can
really start subdividing the the
risk into smaller and smaller uh
percentiles or bins
of risk so obviously with six million
variants one is not limited in the
number of
categories that one can place
individuals in terms of risk
and what that showed us that
was that by using more and more risk
variants
and being able to look at in this case
the top one percentile is illustrated
here
that one could develop polygenic risk
scores
for certain complex disease that had
predictive power
a predictive um uh predictive power
equivalent to
single loss of functional allele so the
comparison here would be for coronary
artery disease this
five-fold increased risk of the top one
percentile of risk
compared to all the other individuals so
that
nearly five to one is similar to what
the increased risk that is
that occurs with variants that cause
familial hypercholesterolemia
so similarly for a number of other uh
disease conditions you can see that the
top
the individuals at the highest risk have
risk which is
many multiples of what the general
population risk
is so what is the implications of that
so again
using the sticking with the example of
cardiovascular risk which is i think
where we
we have the clearest picture of the
potential utility of polygenic risk
scores
there's a a standard approach the pooled
co pooled
cohort equation approach where one uses
a number of different clinical factors
this illustrated here is cholesterol
smoking blood pressure
also included our diabetes status etc
gives you a relative risk prediction
so polygenic risk can also give you a
relative risk prediction
and importantly uh what has been
recognized is that the risk of the
pooled cohort equation factors
is independent of that of the polygenic
risk so in other words
polygenic risk gives you another
powerful indicator of cardiovascular
risk
so then that allows then a combined risk
to be uh to be potentially calculated
where the clinical risk
and the polygenic risk are combined
together to give different risk
categories
so that gives us an idea of how
polygenic risk factors can be applied in
the in the clinic
as i said cardiovascular risk is
something where we
are used to thinking about um uh
primary prevention secondary prevention
so managing
the clinical situation the clinical
factors with with medication and
lifestyle changes
to avoid um an outcome in that case a
cardiovascular event
in many other disease situations the
ability to predict risk has not been
robust
and therefore the the paradigms the
clinical management approaches for
managing risk have not been uh developed
to that degree but
you can really see from that how the
what the potential possibilities are
so uh i moved on to the next slide a
little bit prematurely but the point is
that is to illustrate um
one of the the greatest barriers to
application of polygenic risk
uh clinically right now and that is that
the data sets that we have for
constructing these risk scores are based
on european populations
it's very graphically as illustrated
here you can see the big fat red
segment of the curve going across in the
middle there
that's the number of individuals who
have been included in genome-wide
association studies there's
colored bars there's a rainbow there at
the bottom of other populations
i'm going to be telling you about the
purple line there
where there's very very few individuals
have been included in
in genome-wide association studies that
is south asians
and then on the right hand side is a a
reminder
of the relative proportion of the of the
global population of the different
groups there and you can see that south
asians make up a very significant
fraction of the global population so
there's a very significant
opportunity to to introduce
polygenic risk prediction into patient
management for south asians
so i'm going to skip past that really
quickly so the question then is we can
recognize this disparity how do we solve
it
i'm going to be telling you a little bit
about studies that i've been involved in
uh that have
sought to address that that that deficit
it's based on a consortium the genome
asia one 100 000 100k
so uh the first phase of this was
published last december in nature i'm
not going to
spend any time talking about that but
tell you about the
the overall approach so that what was
published
there last december i'm going to call
phase one and that was the
uh the uh first part of the efforts to
address this disparity
where we used um whole genome sequencing
of
genomes from uh all across asia asia is
a very large and diverse part of the
world of course
that helped us develop strategies for
more regionally focused efforts
and uh what i'll tell you a little bit
about is phase two
where one of the phase two activities
focused on india
so again using whole genome sequencing
to build
a description of the population
structure and then tools
that will allow genetic studies to be
carried out more effectively and
economically so optimize reference panel
and optimize snip array
and then ultimately what that does is
make it
possible to care to generate large data
sets
case control and other data sets for
disease
in that occurs in south asians it allows
us to have a much better prediction
of genetic risk in south asian
populations
so south asia has very distinct origins
from european populations that's shown
on the left-hand side i won't
spend any time talking about that that's
referring to population history from
tens of thousands of years ago so that's
the top bullet points across the top
that south asian origins are very
different from europeans or east asians
hence the failure of european
genetic data to adequately predict risk
in south asians
there's many many thousands of
population groups there are also strong
founder effects which occur and what
that
implies in terms of genetics is that
functional variants missense
and loss loss of function variants occur
at higher frequency
and then finally there are much higher
rates of endogamy in consanguinity so in
other words the
chances are that um that a
um one's parents um are more closely
related than is common
in europe is is occurs at a higher rate
in south asia
so importantly what we did was we
focused on
data that came from individuals who were
in the health care delivery system so in
other words
individuals who would be sampled in
medical genetic studies
and also importantly given the diversity
the uh of humanity across south asia we
focused on the three corners of the
subcontinent
as capturing the genetic diversity
across the subcontinent so that's shown
there
in the inset map on the left hand side
where we sampled from west bengal and
bangladesh from south india and from
pakistan
so we used high coverage whole genome
sequencing to sample that diversity you
can see in this umap plot
that that's in the middle part that
which which captures the effects of
genetic diversity by
uh clustering together individuals whose
genetic variation
uh is limited between them so people are
genetically similar
and spreads a car apart individuals who
are
um more dissimilar so you can see that
there are three
uh that the three geographic regions the
individuals cluster together
and that they cluster separately and and
you can see of course
a rough map of the subcontinent that is
formed we can recreate the corners
of the geography in the genetic
diversity
and then importantly there is a lot of
substructure so in other words
clustering together and clustering apart
within each of those regions
and we can get a picture of what the the
basis is for that
by using some of the data from our first
phase of our project
where you can see that there's color
dots
overlaying the gray dots of the general
population
and you can see that the colored dots
which are individuals from identified
groups
illustrate what some of those patterns
are in the overall general population
from that data what we did was we
generated
a reference panel so reference panel is
allows one to impute missing genotypes
so a foundation of the genome geno
the giwas era was that relatively sparse
genotyping arrays could be used to
capture
a much larger fraction of the total
variation
essentially by interpolating between
genotypes and
a reference panel allows one to
interpolate
effectively and so uh
what has been a standard is the thousand
genomes
reference panel that's shown here with
the red or orange dots um
and then the blue dots are shown the uh
the um
the uh the output from using the
reference panel that we created from
those um south the large number of south
asian individuals
and what's shown on the x-axis is the
allele frequency
on the y-axis is the um is the um r
square
the accuracy the r squared uh for each
genotype
um where we uh we interpolate
and then we look at the um the um the
accuracy of those interpolate
interpolations those uh imputations and
you can see the thousand genomes never
gets
up above about point uh eight
no matter how common uh the uh the
allele is you know even at a
50 point five minor allele frequency of
0.5 so it's a 50 50 guess um still it
doesn't
uh do tremendously well whereas there's
a significant improvement with the
genome asia phase 2
panel so what that then implies
is that much more
much more accurate genotyping can be
done using snip arrays
with the use of this reference panel
and then what we also did with that data
set of
individuals from across south asia is we
generated a new genotyping array so
again
it's relatively sparse compared to the
overall
number of amount of variation in the
genome but by combining this
new genotyping array together with the
reference panel there's
we can create very dramatic improvements
in the ability to genotype
uh south asians at a uh
uh cost which is much lower than using
um high coverage whole genome sequencing
so what's illustrated here is the number
of variants that are
directly genotyped uh the number of
variants that affect protein coding
capacity
on the new array on the left hand side
versus a standard array the illumina gsa
array
and you can see that we are genotyping
many more functional variants in the
genes
in the genome with this new array so
that combined
with the improved imputation of the
reference panel produces a much
dramatic improvements and ability to um
to carry out large scale data sets which
will then
allow much improved
risk scores so the the phase three
i had on on the overall strategy and
this is what is meant by phase three
which is really combining these tools
together with high quality
patient uh population data data sets uh
sample and and uh database clinical
database sets
to create um a very large uh clinical
genomic databases that will allow
effective and accurate
will allow economically the creation of
very large scale data sets
so i will stop there
there's many individuals who have
contributed to all the work everything
i've said i've tried to have citations
on the slide for the
for the literature citations but i have
many collaborators um
that have contributed to the work i
summarized at the end
thank you